You know, we've been working on this new
version of order flows trader. This is
order flows trader six, you know, since
since basically since 2015,
we've you know, come out with several
upgrades over the years and they've
always been free to our users.
Um, you know, I'm a big believer in not
just creating software, but you know,
you always want to be improving it,
right? Make it better than it was in the
previous version, you know, by adding
more forms of order flow analysis. And
you know, it it still shocks me because
I still see a lot of the software out
there, you know, that's on the market
since
I first released the order flows trader
software in 2015 that still looks the
same.
And it's it's just one of those things
that's like, you know, where's the
innovation? I mean, you know, are people
that creating the software using it for
for trading or are they just software
creators that just want to get a product
out there
and and that's it, you know, you know,
for me the whole point of creating the
order flows trader software is because
you know, I was trading with order flow
and I know that software
you can tell it what to look for. You
can tell it to do things for you. So,
um, you know, when we first released the
first version of order flows trader
in 2015, it had um, four
forms of order flow analysis built into
it. Now it's got, you know, over 20 and
it's you know, it's just been remarkable
because you know, sometimes some of the
concepts or ideas that you see in order
flows trader come from my conversation
with other traders that are using the
software saying, you know, Mike, you
know, maybe we could make this
adjustment or hey, can you show this?
And it's really, you know, been
developed to help traders, you know,
understand what's happening in the
market.
So,
the way I like to describe it, you know,
order flows trader six is
something that's going to take you by
the hand and you know, whether you're a
beginning trader with order flow or
intermediate or even advanced, you know,
it's going to take you by the hand and
get you to where you need to be in
market analysis.
You know, sometimes I tell people, you
know, this is as as close you can
be to having, you know, me sitting next
to you saying, "Hey, you know what?" You
know, looking over your shoulder,
pointing at your screen, "This is
happening in the market. That's
happening in the market."
Now,
the Order Flow Suite Trader software is
You know, I said,
"Now, the big change in the software is
we're able to plot um things in the
order flow." And, you know, when you're
looking at a chart, you're going to see
up and down arrows. I'm going to get to
the the the live charts here in a
second, but you know, I just want to
sort of ease you into it because it it
is a big change for um for everybody
because, you know, previous versions of
the Order Flow Suite Trader didn't have
that ability to
uh disable certain functions and
only put on, you know, the things of the
order flow that you want to look at. You
know, in the past, it was
always concentrate on the things that
resonate with you. Well, now, it's going
to take it a step further. You can
concentrate on the things in the order
flow that resonate with you.
And you can take off the things of the
order flow that we've already got in the
software that, you know, you you don't
really look at. Okay, say you don't want
to look at you know, order flow
sequencing, you can take it off your
chart.
And, you know, there's a lot of
functionality along that goes along with
it. So, just really quick, um
the
19 order flow-based forms of analysis
that we have in the Order Flow Suite
Trader software that are
plottable.
Meaning, it's going to plot the up and
down triangle, which, you know, is
useful if you're using, you know, like a
strategy software, you know, strategy
analyzer, things like markers, etc.,
that need to read a plot, right? So, you
if you're building a a strategy around
and it's the prominent point of control
is the order flow tails, the delta
divergence,
exhaustion prints, imbalance reversals,
market sweeps, market weakness,
order flow sequencing, the POC
slingshot, uh the zero prints, value
area. Well, I mean, you know, I mean,
everybody's going to have a value area.
I don't know if you need to plot it, but
um you know, it's there. I haven't
you know, I haven't done any strategies
with the value areas, but you know, it's
probably going to get to that point, you
know, I think in the next We're doing a
lot of stuff with the value areas
that you know, down the line it's it's
going to be um very useful to you. Um
the engulfing value areas, inverse
imbalance, stacked imbalance, thin
prints,
um
the order flows ratios, you know,
there's two types. There's price
exhaustion, price defense, and the
multiple imbalances. Now,
we've also added a new indicator called
thin prints.
And we've made improvements to things
like the value area, the inverse
imbalances, multiple imbalances, um the
order flows
ratios, you know, the price exhaustion
and price defense. Now, we also have um
three new visual
um we want to call it analysis tools and
it deals with the delta in the bars.
And you know, these are not plottable,
but
what they do is they enhance your
understanding of what's happening in the
market. And it's the delta divided by
volume.
And actually um
we even have a
there's actually another thing in there,
um the delta divided by volume on the
extreme, which I'll talk about. We have
extreme deltas, which is when delta is
near to its highest reading or
um you know, either positive or
negative, meaning
that the aggressive traders were
overwhelmingly dominant in a bar, either
buying or selling. We have small min max
delta readings, which indicates you when
there's a lack of min delta or lack of
max delta and
you know why that's important is because
when you lack
aggressiveness one side or the other,
you know, every bar is going to have
aggressive traders, buyers or sellers
um
in the bar.
But when it's really lacking, right?
It's
that's also a sign to you. It's one
thing to have very strong um delta
directionally, you know, either
positive or negative, but when you have
absolutely no positive or negative
strength in a bar, that's also something
you want to key in on. You know, most
traders only look at you know, when
something is strong or weak, but
really what you want to look at also is
when there's lack of something happening
in the order flow. Now, these indicators
were developed to help traders
understand, you know, the strength of
aggressive trading taking place in the
market. So, delta is a difference
between aggressive buyers, aggressive
sellers in a bar. So, any clue to
determine when one side is either very
strong or very weak is going to help you
understand the current
All right, so, you know, enough of the
uh screenshots. Let's uh take a look at
uh some charts.
Now,
for those of you that already have the
order flows traders software, all you
have to do is just simply uninstall and
install the new one. And and it's it's a
simple process, honestly. It's uh
all you have to do if you were going to
do it, you know, you would just go to
your NinjaTrader control panel really
quick and go to remove NinjaScript
Assembly
under the tools.
It's going to pull up that box. You just
scroll down to it and you'll find it and
you just click on there and click
remove. Um to install it,
what you have to do is you just download
the zip file in the link that I give you
and you just simply import the zip file.
You don't need to unzip the file and
look around in there
because
that's not what that's not how you
import
an add-on into NinjaTrader. You just go
to tools on your control panel, click on
import NinjaTrader add-on.
And then just, you know, find um, you
know, where you saved it, you know,
usually I save it in my downloads
folder.
But you just
find it and then you click on okay and
then,
you know, take the it'll take literally
about 30 seconds to import.
And then you're going to enter your
license. So once it's in there, then you
just enter your license token and
yeah, you you open up a new chart. So
let's just go through the whole opening
up the chart process cuz it's very easy.
You do not need a template.
Um,
you know, you you just make sure you
have tick replay enabled. And if you
don't have this choice of tick replay,
um, sometimes people don't realize that
they think it's
they don't see that, they think it's on
there. But if you go to your tools and
options market data,
you see this thing show tick replay it's
got a check that knows
that it's going to show it to you. If if
that is unchecked, when you go to open a
new chart,
uh, it's going to not give you the
choice of using tick replay. You see
nothing here.
So what you have to do, if you see
nothing, that doesn't mean it's on,
right? That means you need to go in and
enable it.
So you just go there, check that box,
enable tick show tick replay and then
you just go to open up your chart.
Gold. This case I'll do gold. You know,
you don't need to do so many days. Um,
you know, just the last couple of days
or so
is fine. You don't need to load 30 days.
I know some people like to do 30 days
worth, but remember, every time you open
up your charts and you have 30 days
worth of data
downloading historical data, it's going
to take a while.
Okay? It's not going to be instant
because you know, the order flow is
trader software is using the tick
replay. So it's got to analyze that data
and put it into the chart. So
we'll just do a simple regular
um, you know, NinjaTrader chart, right?
The default for NinjaTrader is black.
Okay? But, we don't read
black newspapers with white text, right?
We read the opposite. We read, um,
you know,
black text on on a white paper. So,
I'll show you how to change that in a
second, but just to load the indicator,
all you have to do
is you just open up your indicator
setting, go to Order Flow Suite Trader,
and click.
So, make sure it shows up down here
under a configured.
Then, you just going to enter your
license token.
Again, that's in your email, and then
click apply.
And, you know, just wait for it to load.
The
Again, the first time you load a chart,
it's got to pull in the data, so it may
take a little while. Now, you're going
to say, "I can't read this." That's
because the chart is optimized for a
white background. Um,
again, I think it's easier on the eyes,
you know, if you're staring at a chart
all day long, um, like me, and I've done
pretty much my entire professional
career, I prefer the white back- ground.
This is easier. Now,
to change it, what you do is you click
on properties, right? So, you don't need
a a template, right? This chart the
default settings of the Order Flow Suite
Trader is set up for a
1-minute E-mini chart, which is fine
for, you know, every market.
The If you're trading Nasdaq, you may
going to adjust a few things, you know,
depending on the markets you're trading,
but for most markets, the default is
fine. So, you open up the properties,
scroll down the middle, you see colors,
um,
chart background is black, you just
change it to white.
Okay?
Uh, cross
hairs label, you don't really need to
worry about that, but, um, the one you
got change also is text, right? That's
the text on the side of the chart.
Um, slate gray isn't going to do you
much good. Uh,
I prefer to change it to black.
Also, the access, right? It's slate
gray. The access is this line on the
sides, on the bottom and on the side.
Um when you have a white background with
slate gray, you can't read it.
Change that to black. Cross hairs.
Again,
you're going to want to change that to
black. The other thing is the
um
font size, right? For the time and the
price, I prefer something bigger.
Uh you can just change it to something
like 16.
That's it. Boom.
Simple.
All right, so
this is your chart here. Let me just Uh
you know what I got in the background.
This other chart here is crude, but uh
let's stick with this gold chart. Now,
we we've got a lot of tools inside the
Order Flows Trader 6 version, okay?
And
we have some global settings,
which
these settings up here control
everything that you're going to see
inside um
you know, all the different indicators.
And basically, you know, that signal
spacing in ticks, which is the plots
that are being plotted above and below a
bar. Um one is the One is fine, don't
need to change that. The value area
percent, because we have some value area
tools.
All right, we have the engulfing value
area, and we have the regular value
area. Default is set to 70, which is
70%.
Um which is fine. I mean, some people
look at value areas of 50% as well, so
it's up to you.
But 70% is, you know, the one standard
deviation that you're going to look for.
Minimal imbalance volume. And what this
This one is related to anything
imbalance related.
Um you know, imbalance reversals, we
have inverse imbalance, um stacked
imbalance,
and just regular imbalances.
Actually, on the inverse imbalance, we
do also have that setting in here, but
um you can control it from up here. And
what that means is 10. So, for example,
if you have a price level in a bar,
you know, in the two-way auction,
um
let me find one here.
We'll call it
Where is Where is it? You know, one
against eight right in here, right?
Eight on the bid, one trade on the
offer.
Well, even though that's an imbalance,
by setting the minimal
imbalance volume to 10, it's got to be
at least 10 here, right? So, eight
doesn't qualify.
But, if it was set to, say, five,
meaning you could have one against five,
then it would show an imbalance.
I sort of like to have, you know, a bit
stronger imbalances in terms of volume.
You know, 10 is about as minimum as as I
think you wanted go. But, if you didn't
have that
turned on, you know, zero against one
would show up as an imbalance,
um
which is not really something you want
to, you know, really look at.
You know, seven against zero. Yeah,
that's an imbalance, but, you know,
it's only seven contracts, right? So,
you know, at least having 10 is is
is enough for, um you know, to qualify.
Again, you know, you could set it as low
as you want. Um I prefer a setting of uh
10. Now, the imbalance triggering
percent,
default is set to 400. That means an
imbalance of 400 to one. Oh, sorry, four
to one. So, it's 400%, not 400 to one.
It's four to one.
Um again, you could adjust that. Say you
want to use three to one, you just
change it to 300. Again, it's in
percent, so it's 300%, meaning it's
going to be 300% greater.
If you want a higher number,
10 to one, set it at 1,000, okay? And
again, that imbalance triggering percent
is going to affect
anything that is imbalance related,
imbalance reversal, inverse volume
imbalance,
um
you know, the the stacked imbalances,
the
um
down here we've got um
volume imbalance, right? We even got the
multiple imbalance um
in the bars as well. So,
those are those global settings. Now,
again, we we've got, you know, a whole
laundry list of indicators programmed
inside of the Order Flows Trader. Now,
the default has some enabled, some
disabled. And
these are the ones that I focus on in
most markets, okay? Now,
things that are disabled, like market
sweep,
okay? I I disabled that because I know
there's a lot of people that trade MNQ,
um YM, you know, some of the thinner
indices
that just don't trade a lot of volume.
And if you're not trading a lot of
volume,
um
you're going to see a lot of potential
sweeps. And the reason being, you know,
it when there's not a lot of volume,
people are buying it up and selling it
down through several price levels at
once. And technically, that is a sweep,
but that's not the type of sweep that
I'm looking for. I'm really looking for
sweeps, um
you know, in
sort of normal conditions that sort of
come out of nowhere.
Okay? And And what that means is, you
know, S&P's are just sort of plotting
along and then all of a sudden a big
buyer comes in and and buys it up
through four price levels. That That's
the sweeps that I'm looking for.
But again, it's disabled um just so as
not to necessarily confuse uh people
right off the bat because it can really
clutter up a chart on a thinly traded
market. Now, um a couple of the other
ones that are disabled is thin prints.
Even though this is a new indicator,
and it's meant for markets that trade
decent volume at each price level. Um
so, like crude oil here, right? This is
a crude chart. You know, I I granted
it's
Monday morning, Columbus Day.
A lot of traders are off today.
So, you're going to see, you know, not
necessarily a lot of volume uh going
through
at prices. So, thin prints is designed
to look for thin areas
in the order flow, right? So, I would
see something like 0 0 0 like right in
here
is technically a thin print, but it's
also due to the fact that today is kind
of a quiet day.
Um
a couple of the other ones that are are
turned or say turned off, but disabled.
Um
Uh
what was it here? Also thin prints.
Unfinished business. I I don't uh turn
on I don't use that. So, where is it in
here?
Right here. It's there if you want. I I
don't also throw up the volume profile
on my chart, but it's there as well. So,
let's uh sort of take a look at some of
these things. Now, all of them, right?
You'll see
have a check here to enable the
indicator, right? If it's enabled, it'll
have a check there. If it's not enabled,
it won't have a check.
Now, some
like uh the buying and selling tail also
have a couple extra filters like check
EVA, which is engulfing value area, or
check higher high or higher low.
Meaning
it's, you know, check EVA means if you
have tails enabled, uh it would only
signal if there's an engulfing value
area, which is useful in markets like uh
mini Dow, right? They they
when you have a tail,
buying or selling tail in a bar with a
engulfing value area, it it's a pretty
high percentage trade. That's why we
have it in there.
Um check higher high or higher low,
meaning it would have to be
the tail would have to come in at
either a higher high for a selling tail
or a lower low for a buying tail. Now,
there's draw modes on everything, right?
You could draw out the zones of
every indicator in here.
Um most are fixed
to appear just in that bar. Okay, so you
can see fixed
with a zone size of one,
meaning that it's just going to draw in
that bar. Now, if you were to change it
to say, you know, a zone of five, what
it's going to do is it's going to draw
it out five bars starting at the bar
that it appears. So, if you have it um
set to five, it's going to draw out,
you know, over the next uh four bars, as
you can see.
Um
you know,
where is it here?
There's one right here, right? It's
drawing it out over the next 1 2 3 4, so
it's total of five bars.
Now,
the other
feature that we've made available for
all of them is to draw it out until
tested. And if you draw it out until
tested,
doesn't matter what you put in tail, you
know, the zone size, because it's going
to draw it out until tested. And I like
to use this until tested for
many of the indicators. Now, I don't put
them all up on my chart, because it's
going to draw out a lot of zones.
But as you can see here, there was you
know, this zone, right? How the market
often times will come back to these
areas, right? This is another selling
tail right here. The market just, you
know, it came right back to it. Um
you know, this is a tail from earlier.
You can see how the market got right
back within one tick of that
selling tail here, right? This was at
8:00 in the morning.
You know, we came literally one tick
into that zone, right? One tick off of
it, and then, you know, reacted.
Um this is a buying tail, you know, just
sort of went right through.
But
again, you can just see these areas
where
you You the market just, again, comes
right up to these areas. You know, this
was another one. I we got within one
tick of getting into that zone. It's
useful for targets. You know, say you're
long from an area. Okay, well, I know
I've got this overhead zone up here. Or
some people actually, you know, will
will throw offers or bids in the market
uh for retests of those zones.
Um
now
Let's pull up the indicator settings.
So,
it gets tricky, I'll admit, because
you got a lot of different indicators
and
you know, you're trying to keep the
color scheme
um manageable.
Because generally for
you know
I I remember when I was trading Globex
back in the in the early '90s.
Um
I there's I went through like a stretch
of like almost every day for
a week and a half I had silly ticky-tack
errors of
buying when I should have been selling
because I was really just looking at the
screen and and not looking at the
buttons on the keypad. I was just, you
know, pressing the buttons.
And you know, they're just stupid
errors, but it's just like
it's it's a loss, okay? It'd be a
scratch or you know, maybe I lose a tick
cuz I should have bought or sold.
Um you know, I was buying when I should
be selling and and my
boss asked me
"What's your problem? Are you color
blind or something? Blue means buy, red
means sell." And
it's just one of those things or or
green actually is is in the old system
was was for buys.
Um but generally blue is something
that's bullish, red is something that's
bearish and we're trying to keep all
these
um indicators, you know, along that line
of of green or blue for something that's
bullish or buying, red for something
that's selling. Now, you're going to see
some like the delta divergence, which is
gold color.
Okay? And again, you can adjust these
colors however you like it, right?
Market weakness, I've got um
you know, kind of this blue violet and
dark orange, but again, you could adjust
it
however you want it, right? But mostly
you'll see are some sort of shades of
blue and red, um you know, cyan and
magenta even for the prominent point of
controls.
Um
yeah, again, but it's up to you if you
want to change those or not.
Because if you change them,
the plots
whatever
color you change it to is is going to
color the the little up or down
triangle, right? Blue triangle here, red
triangle there, it's going to color it
that color.
Okay? So,
with a lot of different sort of
indicators,
if you're
got each one is a different color,
then
you're going to be sometimes you're
going to be
more worried about what color, you know,
what color is that and you what does
that mean as opposed to oh, you know,
that there's something bullish. Cuz to
be honest, once you start using the
software and you get used to it,
you start seeing okay, yeah, I've got a
um
you know, I've got a red triangle, you
know, I got this one, I got this one
here, I got three. Well, what does that
mean? Well, okay, I I can just look at
the bar and say okay, yeah, I've got
three bearish things in the order flow
here. What do I got? Well, I I know I
got sequencing, you know, I got a
bearish uh slingshot point of control,
cuz that one, and I've got an exhaustion
print.
Okay? Just by looking at the bar, here
this green candle, I've got, you know,
one green triangle. Oh, yeah, let's look
a little closer. I know I've got this um
uh exhaustion print here.
Okay? You know, like here, I got a
bearish prominent point of control on
this bar and I've got a bearish EVA
here. Okay?
Now,
as long as it's, you know, it's bearish
and bullish, I think, you know, over
time, you you'll pick it up really
quick.
Now,
the delta divergence, right? In the
past, the previous version would just
draw a little triangle above or below
the bar.
I've changed it a little bit and I've
made it um
gold gold color. And when it's gold
color, let's see if there was one here
this morning. Um
This is gold as well. Um
let's see.
I have to go back to the evening time.
Ah, I'll go back to the previous day. I
think there was some divergence. That's
uh Where is it?
I'll tell you what, let's just throw on
the uh open.
You know, NinjaTrader, one of the nice
things they have is this current open
day high low close. Um
it's good to have that on your chart.
Cuz obviously the day's high or low is
are important reference points.
Um
you should always uh be aware of where
we're trading. Okay, so here
let's open this up.
You can see it right down here on this
low.
The bottom two price levels are colored
um gold color.
Okay, you can see the little plot is a
gold color plot. That's your delta
divergence. Delta divergence is
a newer new low
with positive delta. So, you can see
here, right? Positive delta 496. You
could even see this one's got 1 2 3 4 5
6 bullish things in the order flow.
Right? Out of the the ones that are
enabled.
Now, that's a good sign, right? Now,
I I don't want you guys falling into
this trap thinking, "Oh, you know what?
This one's got six. It's got to be an
automatic buy."
Um you you still got to follow what's
happening in the order flow. Okay? Don't
just say, "Oh, you know, the more the
better." Yeah, in theory, but
um
you you don't want to just take every
single bar that's got four, five, six,
um
you know, plots of things happening in
the order flow.
Now, one of the other differences,
again,
all the indicators, you can draw out
the um the zones, right? So, again, it's
set to one,
but since a delta divergence is going to
come at a higher the low, maybe you want
to draw it out until tested. So, just
sort of remind you that hey, you know
what? The first time we were there, we
had a divergence.
Let's see what's going to happen, you
know, sort of the second time if we get,
you know,
close to that level. So, I you know,
obviously, it's the low of the day here.
Um you know, nothing there. Then, the
evening session.
Right? You can see here, right? You got
this divergence, this divergence.
This gives you an area, you know,
something else to look at
on your chart.
Um
then, uh just sort of go through
exhaustion prints. You know, exhaustion
prints have been around since the first
version of
Order Flows Trader. And what it does is
it draws, you know, it draws the box
around the exhaustion print in the bar,
um at the top offer of the red candle,
the bottom bid
of a green candle.
Imbalance reversal, it's a little bit
different here. You know, in the
previous versions, we used to draw an up
or down arrow.
Um instead,
what it does here
for bullish imbalance reversals and
bearish, it will draw a box
either light green or red around the top
for
for selling imbalance reversal, it's
going to draw it on a red channel at the
top two prices. On a bullish one, it's
going to draw it on the bottom two.
Let's see if we can uh
find one here.
Uh
let's see.
Okay, right here. This is a
bearish imbalance reversal coming in
right here.
Okay? That's why you got this
red triangle here.
And the box over the two price levels
there.
Okay? And again, you know, if you want
you can draw out
again, for a visual, you can draw it out
until tested. All right, let me just
turn off some of these other ones here.
And
it's going to
it's going to uh you know, draw out
Wait, where is it?
Oh, sorry. That was the exhaustion print
I turned on. Um
until tested.
The imbalance reversal one.
Um until tested. Some traders I know
like to use the exhaustion prints and
draw it out um
you know, since a long time ago.
But it's just amazing how often times
you see the market just come right back
to these levels. That's why we started
drawing them out. Because, you know, I
know some traders have been telling me,
"Mike, you know, I I'm using the
exhaustion prints or I'm using this."
And when this happens, you know, it it
just kicks off a nice level that
um you know, I could look to to trade
around. You know, if it comes back up to
that area, right? Like right here.
Um
you know,
things like that. So, it's just you
know, it's just an added feature that to
help you understand what's happening in
the market and you know, take ideally
take better trades.
Okay?
Um
again, you can see each one is going to
plot.
Right? So, if it's
if there's that thing happening in the
bar,
right? Whether you know, like here,
right? You got divergence in a ratio,
right? You got the gold
the gold up triangle, the um blue up
triangle.
Okay?
Now, I get to those ratios in a minute,
but um
sort of you know, run through some of
these things real quick. Inverse
imbalance. All right, this is one of my
favorites, and the default is drawing
out until tested. Okay, so
and it's set to two clusters, meaning if
you have two opposite imbalances in a
bar, meaning if it's you know, an up
candle and you got
selling imbalances, that's what's called
an inverse imbalance, because you have a
up candle, you're looking for buying
imbalances, not selling imbalances. And
same would be for bearish, right? You'd
have a
a down candle,
but you got buying imbalances. Well,
what's causing that is traders are
getting trapped, because you have people
coming in offering supply to absorb
whatever aggressive buying is there, and
that's uh weighing on the market.
And um you know, I know earlier here in
the crude, there was one
um that came in. Uh where was it?
Uh
Okay.
Right here, this is an inverse
imbalance. Okay?
Buying imbalance, buying imbalance at
the top of this red candle. And this is
um you know, a nice
setup for you know, these markets that
sometimes have a lot of volatility, but
it's also a sign of supply coming into
this market. This market's selling off,
and you can see people are are offered
down. You got this 34 lots, the 21, the
supply coming into the market to keep
this market from coming back up. When it
comes back up, it gets sold back down.
Right? So, again, it it's
the the
the brain
processes images
much faster than processing numbers cuz
if you got to sit there and
think, "Okay, what's happening in this
bar in the order flow?" Like right here,
right? This one is being drawn out from
gosh, who knows where.
Uh where is it?
I saw that.
All right, where did it go?
And it was a buying one here, this one.
Um
1704.
Right here, okay?
This is a green candle. You got the two
sound of bounces. Traders are getting
trapped down here. They're getting over
the excited, the market is selling off.
And they're coming in here sounding but
there's passive buyers there absorbing
that selling. That's why it's drawn um
this blue color to tell you, "Hey, you
know what? This is a bullish thing
that's happening in the order flow." You
see the market just it reacted. I'm not
saying all because 40 contracts got sold
down here
that it causes massive reversal,
but it was a sign in the order flow
that, "Hey, you know what? Traders are
getting a little bit over extended. Um
some traders are getting trapped down
here. The trade is to the upside."
Right? And it just it shot just straight
up. You also got some other things
happening
excuse me, in the order flow. You got
that exhaustion print.
You've got the
um
tails as well going on in there.
So, you know, inverse imbalance is
something that I I've been using in my
trading for a long time and it's it's
quite useful.
And you want something that that's going
to
show it on your chart as opposed to, you
know, show it easily. I mean, it's there
on the chart if you have a regular
footprint. But again, you know,
honestly, if you're looking at
Close this down. If you're looking at a
a footprint like this, right? This is
crude oil. This is a 1-minute This is
the, you know, the volumetric chart from
the order flows uh from the NinjaTrader
8, okay?
Well, first of all, you got to do a lot
you got to do a lot of customization to
understand what you're looking at.
But it's like
Okay,
you know, you really got to you know,
this is why people they get a chart like
this and and this is why they they
discard order flows because
they don't understand what they're
looking at and trying to put it
together, put the pieces together,
understand what's happening.
It's just too much, you know, cuz what
time was this was on Well, this is gold.
But um
You know, if I if I were to pull up the
gold chart
just go back to what day was that? That
was um I think Friday. At what time? 9
here, right?
Let's make it bigger.
This is
This is the volume here. 30 against
four, 30 against four, 10 against two,
10 against two.
You know,
you're not going to pick that up. That's
an inverse imbalance that, you know, is
something you should get long. You're
probably not going to notice that
there's a tails here or or there's an
exhaustion print in here that's bullish
for the bar. I mean, there's a lot of
bullish three bullish things happening
in this bar.
That
un- unless you're like an expert at
reading the order flow, you're not going
to pick it up.
Right? But if you have a tool, right?
Like the Order Flows Trader
it's there, right? It just stands out.
It's obvious for you to see.
Um
Okay, let's just go through a couple
more of these things. Um so what was
that? That was inverse. Now the market
sweep detector
again is disabled.
Um to enable it just put a check there.
And again, I'm going to keep it at
I'm going to keep it very tight. I'll
just keep it at you know two for this
sweep threshold. Um
I'll probably get a lot of sweeps
in the market like gold cuz it doesn't
trade a lot of volume. It's really meant
this sweep detector is meant for things
that trade a lot of volume
like uh
what do you call it? Um
S&P's. But you can see here, right?
Bullish sweeps are going to be green.
Bearish sweeps are going to be red. Now
you know, here's a bullish sweep. Here's
a bearish sweep. Here's a bearish sweep.
Here's a bullish sweep.
The thing to keep in mind is when you're
using something like sweep detector
sweeps are momentum based. Okay, someone
is buying it in a direction. You want to
see the direction keep going.
You have a bullish sweep, you want to be
trading above it.
Okay? You have a bearish sweep, you want
to be trading below it. Now you can
trade into it like this.
But when you have a bearish sweep and
the market is closing above the sweep
that's not a good sign
cuz it's sort of rejecting it. And again
sort of what's causing the sweep is kind
of lack of volume, honestly. But um you
know, when you have a bearish sweep, you
want it to be trading below it. If
you're trading above it, you don't want
to be in that trade. Right? Here's your
bullish sweep. Obviously we're we're
closing above it. Okay?
It's a momentum trade. And you're
trading in the direction of momentum.
If you have something that's bearish,
market should be going lower, not going
higher. Just as if you have something
bullish, market should be going higher,
um,
not lower.
All right, so
again, by default that is, uh, disabled.
More of an advanced thing for traders.
Now, the market weakness detector is
also drawn, so it's enabled, it's drawn
until tested. It's
blue, violet, and dark orange.
Sounds more, um,
yeah, I don't know what the word is, but
it's one of those things that just
stands out, right? Because really with,
um,
market weakness, you know, you
you just want to be alerted to it.
Right? And then and trade it from there.
And I I just found that color scheme,
you know, this line here is market
weakness. You see the market came right
back up to that area and it's just sort
of hanging around there. But
when it appears here,
right? You see how the market had a nice
sell-off. This is a bearish one right
here. And it's going to draw it out from
the top of the bar,
not from the whole bar itself. Again,
you know, when drawing out these zones,
we also had to figure out, you know,
where do we want it to
how do we want it to appear?
You know, at the top, the bottom,
etc. Because I want to show you guys
something when we get to the ratios.
You know, here's some market weakness,
bearish one. Let's see if there's any
bullish
weakness. I think
you know,
let's see here. This is a bullish market
weakness here. We got this little bit of
a rally, but mostly went sideways, came
right back to that level, to the bottom
of that bar
where the weakness first started,
and then went back up.
Um, so that's market weakness.
Now,
sort of moving on some of the other
indicators,
um,
sequencing, right? Again, one of my
favorites. It's default is, um, on, it's
enabled, and you can see in the bars,
right? This is market, uh, bearish
sequencing here.
The cyan in the bar.
Um,
Let's see here. This is today already.
Uh, let's see if there's any bearish or
bullish ones.
Yeah, on on days that are kind of quiet,
here's a bearish sequencing
coming in there. Here's a bullish one.
Not a whole lot today, but again, you
could also draw it out until tested.
Which, you know, again, is is one of
those things that um, you know, for some
people, you know, visual being visual is
is is something that's going to give you
an edge, right? You want you want to be
the best trader that you can be. And
having
literally something right in front of
your eyes,
you know, you see how the market, you
know, here's bearish sequencing, came
right back up into that area. Sequencing
is when the market is taken out
subsequent higher and higher volume
levels or lower and lower volume areas.
So, if the market trades back in there,
right? You want to see these areas where
the aggressive selling was holding,
right? You can see
rallied up, came back off,
rallied back into that zone, came off.
Okay?
So, that's a sequencing. And again, you
know, I've done a lot of videos on
sequencing. Um,
you see, you should you should check
those out if you want to learn more
about sequencing.